[Music]
hyman's with us in
philadelphia hi hyman how are you
hey no dave uh nice uh nice to
get to you thank you for taking my call
sure
i have a question um i recently a storm
had hit the philadelphia chester county
area and
the federal government that came in and
said for folks that had damages uh you
can apply it for some kind of support i
did fill out the application a lot of
folks got um grants and for me they gave
me a loan oh no why'd you do that
yeah everybody else that grant but they
get they offered me a loan i think yeah
i know i'm passionate about my i don't
need a loan yeah with my income
um but so that's what i was calling i
mean i kind of knew the answer that he
was an actor i have about um 45k
in a in a in a emergency fund money
market and i have about 35 about 44k
in a saving account um my basement is
destroyed uh the kids can't plan it and
i want to assist if i should
will it
a contractor is an alternative
credibility so you can fix it for 20
grand and you have 80 grand
i got 44. yes i thought you said you had
44 and you had 40 and something else
in a in a money market account yeah so
you have 80. you have 80 000. don't do
this don't get connected don't take a
loan from the government all of that you
know that you know that
you have the money fix the basement
don't go in debt to the government god
help us
yeah i just paid off you know sixty
thousand dollars in debt so and the only
thing would happen
is our mortgage
is nothing that's awesome i'm glad you
did that that doesn't mean anything to
do with you taking a loan from the
government and worse don't go back into
debt you just got out of debt out of it
man
um can i sneak another question i know
you'll go in time i don't know i don't
know are you going to borrow money from
the government yeah if it's about
borrowing money from the government hey
just hang up
are you going to borrow money i know i
i'm not going to borrow it i know the
answer in that one okay my daughter then
you can ask another question
yeah my daughter is 14 she's about to go
to college we play like i said i just
paid off 6 000 debt no car payment only
car payment only
my debt i have is mortgage um should we
should i be paying extra on my mortgage
are putting more money toward her
college fund she got about four more
years you need to have a plan for her to
go to school debt-free
and uh and beyond that you put money
towards your mortgage but you need to
have a plan you need to map out where
she's gonna go what it's gonna cost
and how much she's gonna work and how
much she's gonna go getting scholarships
and um
how her grades are doing and all of that
kind of stuff and then we go okay this
is what it's going to cost and here's
the money and we're going to set our
goals now five years out
and then based on that you can tell if
you have any money left over
to pay extra on the mortgage but baby
step five is kids college six is pay
extra
on the mortgage i've got we've got a
book out that was a bestseller called
debt free degree it's how to go to
college debt free
i'll send you a copy of that and you
guys can unpack that together and make
out a plan i actually want you to get
four colleges
two one or two that she thinks she wants
to go to one that's in your area and
then a what i would call a fallback like
a like a
here's a good place we can go to college
it's gonna be an economical choice and
run those numbers that david's talking
about on all of them and you can spread
them across and see what your options
are and what you're thinking about and
then you can save twitter you can ask
yourself yeah is that degree over there
really worth more than that same degree
over here exactly you can ask yourself
that question and you'll probably say
nope
but it's a good idea to lay it out it's
a great exercise
this is the ramsey show